max weber l'éthique protestante et
l'esprit du capitalisme
max weber est née en 1864 en
confédération germanique dans une
famille de la bourgeoisie protestante
il étudie successivement le droit
l'économie politique la philosophie
l'histoire et la théologie avant de se
consacrer à la sociologie il écrira en
1904 pour la première partie et en 1905
pour la seconde partie l'éthique
protestante et l'esprit du capitalisme
qui restera son oeuvre principale
comme les grands philosophes de son
époque qui se consacre de plus en plus à
la sociologie il va baliser cette
discipline et être considéré comme l'un
de ses pères fondateurs à l'instar
d'auguste compte d'emile durkheim ou de
karl marx
enfin max weber décédera en 1920 en
allemagne dans l'éthique protestante et
l'esprit du capitalisme
max weber va tenter de comprendre les
liens qui unissent la religion
protestante du capitalisme
pour rappel la religion protestante est
une religion issues du christianisme qui
tendent à se séparer du catholicisme
cette religion sera d'abord théorisée
par luther qui vous feront fournée son
église et ensuite par calvin cela reste
les deux grandes tendances du
protestantisme actuellement auquel on
doit bien sûr ajouter l'anglicanisme le
capitalisme
quant à lui représente le système
économique qui est caractérisée par la
propriété privée des moyens de
production et l'accumulation de capital
grâce aux profits réalisés qui sont
réinvestis dans les entreprises
le texte de max weber reste aujourd'hui
une référence incontournable pour qui
veut comprendre l'émergence du
capitalisme en occident la problématique
de l'éthique protestante et l'esprit du
capitalisme émane d'un triple constat
statistique
que fera max weber tout d'abord il
constate que les protestants sont sur
représentées sont plus nombreux parmi
les chefs d'entreprise et les détenteurs
de capitaux mais aussi que les
travailleurs plus qualifiés sont des
protestants
il remarque en même temps que parmi les
catholiques
beaucoup choisissent des études
secondaires d'humanité alors que les
protestants choisi plutôt des branches
commerciales
enfin il constatera que les petits
artisans catholiques restent dans leur
milieu tandis que les artisans
protestants eux n'hésitent pas à
rejoindre l'industrie moderne
le premier constat peut aisément
s'expliquer par le fait que les
protestants et en plus riches à la base
grâce à leur économie individuels vont
plus vite
fondé des fortunes mais en ce qui
concerne les petits artisans qui
rejoignent l'industrie moderne et les
étudiants qui ont très peu de capitaux
l'explication ne tient pas max weber des
sites d'investiguer plus loin
la question à laquelle max weber va
tenter d'apporter une réponse est très
simple
en quoi la religion protestante
donne-t-elle des qualités qui permettent
de réussir dans une société capitaliste
pour max weber
la première tâche est d'établir un
portrait-robot de l'esprit du
capitalisme
pour lui le capitalisme moderne
correspond un rapport au temps le temps
c'est de l'argent
le crédit est aussi de l'argent il coûte
de l'argent
il faut donc épargné épargné pour faire
grossir doucement sa fortune
le travail l'honnêteté l'élimination du
gaspillage
c'est à dire toute optimisation du
profit devient essentielle la recherche
du gain le plus élevé devient une fin en
soi
le gain est désormais une valeur
attention on ne recherche pas
systématiquement l'argent en tant que
tel et ce n'est pas non plus ce que
l'argent permet que recherche le
capitaliste moderne
non lui ce qu'il veut c'est réussir
c'est gagné atteindre ces objectifs
une recherche rationnelle et
systématique du profit par l'exercice
d'une profession scène
ça va donc à l'encontre d'une recherche
de tout profit à court terme
d'entrepreneurs peu scrupuleux qui
recherchent à faire de l'argent sur le
dos des autres
non l'entrepôt l'entrepreneur
capitaliste lui table sur le moyen /
long terme il veut réussir dans la durée
max weber
on vient à établir trois profils tout
d'abord l'entrepreneur traditionnelle
qui veut juste satisfaire ses besoins
personnels qui consacre tout son temps à
la routine et leurs rapports amicaux
les amis sont plus importants que les
affaires et on fera certainement à bon
prix a une relation très proche
et puis si on peut travailler de manière
très modérée c'est beaucoup mieux le
deuxième profil établi par max weber et
celui de l'homme d'affaires peu
scrupuleux qui existe depuis très
longtemps
cet homme d'affaires est aventureux il
essaie de d'atteindre des gains rapides
est vraiment sans scrupules ils écrasera
son prochain si besoin
enfin le dernier type d'entrepreneur et
les entrepreneurs capitalistes modernes
qui recherchent le profit par le biais
d'innovations par la saisie de toutes
les opportunités qui se présentent à lui
sur le marché il mais ça qu'on la
concurrence à genoux ainsi que ses
fournisseurs dont ils exigent le
meilleur et meilleur prix
il régule lui-même ses prix pour
conquérir de nouvelles parts de marché
et pour faire prospérer son activité son
entreprise il rationnalise rationalise
le travail a une attitude sobre
travaille énormément et accorde une
importance considérable à l'épargné de
l'autre côté max weber va étudier
l'éthique protestante et en particulier
la doctrine calviniste qui considère la
prédestination comme une réalité dès sa
naissance chaque homme voit son sort
scellé par dieu certains sont voués à
l'enfer et d'autres seront élus pour le
paradis
il s'agit d'un décret vidic divin
irrévocable on ne pourra jamais le
changer et insondable personne ne le
connaîtra avant la mort dans ce contexte
chaque croyant se pose la question
suis-je élus vais-je pouvoir rejoindre
le paradis ou devrais je vivre pour
l'éternité dans les enfers
et on pourrait penser que face à une
telle représentation les calvinistes
vont s'enfermer dans un certain fatigue
fatalisme
à quoi bon finalement faire le bien
autour de moi à quoi bon écoutez dieu si
tout est prévu et si je ne peux rien
changer
ça va être tout à fait l'un vers ce qui
va se passer les protestants vont
travailler sans relâche
ils vont travailler sans relâche tout
d'abord pour évacuer toute cette
pression
finalement et cette impossibilité de
changer le destin et ils vont aussi
travailler pour montrer qu'ils sont
peut-être l'élu ils vont essayer
d'assurer leur réussite
car si dieu les a choisis ils doivent
réussir
et s'ils réussissent ils auront la
certitude qu'ils feront partie des élus
dans ce contexte gaspillé son temps et
plus grave le plus grave de tous les
péchés et ce qui est condamnée dans la
société calviniste c'est le repos dans
la possession l'oise yves thé et les
tentations de la chair
le travail devient une valeur suprême on
comprend que dans ce contexte les
calvinistes vont profondément développer
un habitus capitaliste puisqu'ils vont
augmenter la valeur travail ils vont
tout faire pour atteindre le succès et
la réussite et c'est justement ce que
veut l'entrepreneur capitaliste
en diminuant sa consommation c'est à
dire en refusant tous les plaisirs de la
chair en évitant les amusements qui
coûte de l'argent et du temps il pourra
également augmenté son épargne et avoir
plus de capital pour le réinvestir et
voilà la deuxième façon pour laquelle la
deuxième raison pour laquelle les
protestants calviniste sont de bons
capitalistes weber par son étude a donc
bien réussi à montrer que l'éthique
protestante calviniste était la variable
explicative finalement de la réussite
capitaliste de certains individus
voici la bibliographie qui a été
consulté pour la réalisation de cet
exposé tout d'abord un très bon résumé
dans les grands auteurs de la sociologie
par henri mendras ce et jean étienne aux
éditions hatier l'éthique protestante et
l'esprit du capitalisme est relativement
accessible est toujours consultable dans
de nouvelles versions comme ici la
version flammarion dans les chants
classiques et enfin je vous propose sur
youtube une vidéo en anglais de sept
minutes qui vous permet de faire le
point sur tous les acquis puisque outre
l'éthique protestante et l'esprit du
capitalisme max weber a est l'auteur de
nombreux autres travaux que vous pourrez
comprendre
en tout cas esquissé par cette petite
vidéo je vous remercie de votre
attention et je vous souhaite une bonne
continuation dans vos lecture
sociologique